[Musica]
perché questo quadro
questo quadro mi accompagna sin da
quando ho memoria ce lo ha in casa da
sempre
e più volte
sin da piccolissimo mi sono ritrovato a
contemplare nel significato col passare
degli anni col passare del tempo questo
quadro assunto un significato ben
preciso per me
guardiamo un attimo che cosa vedete
una semplicissima strada come tante che
si addentra nel bosco
poi c'è una curva e dietro
l'ignoto
che sensazioni di suscita l'idea di
ritrovarvi davanti all'ignoto pensiamo
questa immagine a quante situazioni
quante situazioni nella nostra vita
quotidiana
si sposano con questa immagine
dell'ignoto pensiamo a qualsiasi tipo di
scelta infiniti esempi
quando ci si ritrova davanti alla
possibilità della scelta di lasciare gli
studi perché non riusciamo più vedere il
valore aggiunto la possibilità sentire
la sensazione della della possibilità
della scelta di lasciare un partner
perché non è più quell'ideale di
lasciare un lavoro perché non ci ha mai
appassionato o che non ci appassiona più
non ci risentiamo realizzati o la
possibilità di costruire una realtà
industriale un'azienda
l'ignoto la paura di sbagliare
la maggior parte di noi agisce davanti
all'ignoto
con sensazioni negative
di rifiuto
di timore di paura
sin da piccolissimo però mi sono reso
conto che per me l'ignoto
e il concetto che più affascina non vedo
il mio atto come possibile fonte di
paura
di rischi ma vedo l'ignoto come la più
grande possibile fonte di meraviglie è
sempre stato così ma sin da piccolissimo
non avevo assolutamente idea
come molti di noi non abbiamo idea di
quale il nostro scopo esistenziale in
che direzione può andare alla nostra
vita infinite quindi spesso quando c'è
una possibilità infinita di decisioni ci
si ritrova davanti a una paralisi
decisionale
mi sono reso conto ad esempio durante i
normali anni delle delle scuole
superiori che mi si ritrovava in un
ambiente in cui non ero assolutamente
più più più stimolato non riuscivo a
trovare
la risposta a tutte le domande sono
sempre stato un ragazzino sin da piccolo
con moltissime domande sempre
continuamente mi sono reso conto di
essere più interessato alle domande che
alle risposte perché se ci pensate
veramente difficile porre
delle domande giuste e corrette
importanti la sfida principale porci le
giuste domande perché poi
una diretta conseguenza è la risposta
ed è più semplice mi sono reso conto che
potevo scegliere se pensare per analogia
intraprendere uno qualsiasi dei
possibili percorsi che vedevo fare ai
miei simili che ovviamente richiede un
energia
mentale assai inferiori oppure poter
prendere un'altra strada quella del
rendermi conto che non avevo abbastanza
dati esperenziali non sapevo come
funzionava il mondo non sapevo che cosa
che cosa ammasso di assi fare e quindi
ho deciso di intraprendere una fase
della mia vita chiamata la fase
esplorativa per anni durante gli anni
dell'università ho girato il più
possibile mi sono ritrovato a vivere
quasi tutti i continenti
ero davvero curioso di capire come
funzionasse la fuori senza basarmi su
consigli degli altri del di quello che
era il mio ambiente d'origine
estremamente ristretto e quindi mi sono
ritrovato
ad espormi a dinamiche culturali in
tutti i tipi imprenditoriale di
moltissimi tipi
culturali o sociali
e questo mi ha portato ovviamente ad
affrontare tantissime situazioni diverse
sia positive che negative
ovviamente inevitabile quando si esplora
l'ignoto compiere errori
il segreto è compiere quando si compiono
errori compierli
compierle a prendere dei seal nel modo
più velocemente possibile così da
implementare e migliorare rapidamente
menziono 22 delle cose che potremmo
definire negative a incidenti di
percorso che succedono tutti a volte mi
è capitato una volta di ritrovarmi in
una zona di un paese dove non sarei
dovuto arrivare fino a dove non sarei
dovuto spingermi stavo per essere
sequestrato e una decina di giorni fa
durante il mio corso da pilota ho avuto
un bruttissimo incidente
siamo letteralmente precipitati con
l'aero in stallo ed ero certo certo di
morire di certo non mi aspettavo di
essere oggi qui a raccontarlo invece
andata bene e
sono riuscito a fare sopravvivere anche
a rimanere illeso
una nota
curiosa è che dopo l'incidente ho preso
il telefono dopo pochi minuti dopo
l'incidente sto ancora tremando
chiamo mio padre e gli dico
devo dirti una cosa un lungo sospiro
dall'altra parte mio padre dice che cosa
è successo questa volta sto bene non ti
preoccupare siamo precipitati alla ero
distrutto ma sto bene un altro sospiro
dall'altra parte e la voce di mio padre
che dice è davvero difficile
essere i tuoi genitori
grazie
ma di nuovo è inevitabile
compiere errori
e ovviamente la paura attanaglia pensate
quanta paura io possa avere in questo
momento a ricominciare continuare il
corso da pilota ma
miley che subentra quella scintilla
divina che ci distingue da tutte le
altre specie ovvero non reagire per
istinti ma prendere il controllo essere
razionali analizzare con razionalità ha
cassato un errore umano che ha posto la
macchina una condizione di non volare
ovviamente a volte la razionalità non
basta ed è lì che arriva la motivazione
la motivazione
il motivo
il nostro scopo esistenziale e quella
stella
che guida il nostro cammino mentre
fronte all'ignoto
e mentre quindi
affrontato questa fase di raccolta di
informazioni in giro per il mondo un
giorno
ero nel volo mi ricordo esattamente il
momento stavo tornando dall'asia verso
l'europa
da da mosca l'amburgo
e
quell'anno era il 2015 e avevo era quasi
natale avevo affrontato avevo preso 50
voli e
qualcosa inizia germania nella mia testa
un'idea un concetto
ovvero
mi sono reso conto di quanto ormai è
semplice raggiungere qualsiasi punto del
pianeta in modo piuttosto semplice e
meno di 24 ore possiamo raggiungere
qualsiasi punto del pianeta pensate che
ogni giorno in media
100 mila aerei decollano e atterrano se
prendiamo in considerazione nella durata
media di un volo di circa 2 ore
significa che ogni giorno ci sono 6
circa 6 milioni di persone almeno 6
milioni di persone che si spostano da un
punto all'altro della terra
e la fiamma che ahimè dell'esploratore
di essere sempre alle frontiere mi ha
fatto rendere conto che ormai non c'era
più nulla
di abbastanza rilevante da esplorare
sulla terra mi sono reso conto e mi sono
reso conto
è se avessimo e se creassimo il modo per
accedere per accedere con la stessa
semplicità con la quale vediamo oggi a
venire voli intercontinentali da un
punto all'altro della terra accedere
anche allo spazio in questo modo ma non
avevo assolutamente idea di come
realizzare costruire un veicolo del
genere una flotta di veicoli del genere
una realtà industriale del genere
ed è così che il mio cercare che mi
esplorare mi porta ad incontrare due
degli individui più incredibili che io
abbia mai incontrato nella mia vita
mattia massimiliano e assieme
ora ci ritroviamo a costruire
una giovane realtà industriale
iniziamo a sviluppare un design ci
chiariamo le idee abbiamo le idee molto
precise ma non abbiamo ancora idea se è
possibile costruire una realtà tanto
innovativa in italia eravamo però pronti
a tutto a qualsiasi cosa spostarci
ovunque pur di portare in vita un'idea
del genere abbiamo anche iniziato a
costruire un prototipo un primissimo
prototipo carol
poi però riusciamo a trovare problema
degli investitori in italia coraggiosi
come noi e tutto questo è successo
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo e le cose
continuano a crescere ad aumentare
apriamo una seconda sede operativa
al nord cerchiamo di portare a bordo i
migliori talenti che sono
allineati come nella nostra visione di
lungo periodo
iniziamo a testare
motore estremamente
innovativi perché il concetto che c'è
dietro è il seguente
stiamo realizzando qualcosa che
completamente diverso da
ciò che esiste nel mercato spaziale dei
lanciatori ovvero veicoli spaziali che
sono in grado di raggiungere la bassa
orbita terrestre tornare
decidiamo di sviluppare un veicolo e
attualmente testare un veicolo che
riesce a raggiungere lo spazio
ed essere pronto al decollo nel giro di
poche ore che può essere lanciato da
ovunque senza bisogno di infrastrutture
di lancio
cosa che attualmente non esiste perché
nel mondo ci sono altri lanciatori di
dimensioni enormi che possono essere
lanciati solo da pochissimi siti di
lancio che richiedono costi
infrastrutture multi milionari un
veicolo dai costi
bassissimi ma soprattutto estremamente
piccolo estremamente piccolo è il primo
singolo stadio verso l'orbita della
storia della storia dello spazio
ed è in grado di avere estremamente
versatile in grado di avere le
applicazioni più svariate il
parallelismo che ci piace fare
gli sta ritrovando riscontra un po
quello con il personal computer quando
venite e stato operato il personal
computer che era estremamente
inefficiente rispetto ai grandi
supercomputer che a quell'epoca si
trovavano solamente in pochi centri di
ricerca nel pianeta una macchina molto
più inefficiente ma anche potente
abbastanza dare al potere potenzialmente
a chiunque università centri di ricerca
aziende private in singoli ricercatori
di operare in piena indipendenza le
proprie missioni con uno o una flotta di
questi veicoli e addirittura la
potenzialità non solo di rilanciare
piccoli satelliti o portare su una
costellazione di satelliti il mouse
orbita terrestre ma addirittura esporre
qualsiasi tipo di esperimento di life
science con moltissime applicazioni in
ambito farmaceutico e o qualsiasi altra
qualsiasi tipo di tom componentistica
che qualsiasi azienda vuole sviluppare
per prodotti devoti poi all'economia
dello spazio possono essere portati e
rimanere in orbita per un periodo però
inizialmente che va tra le 12 ore fino
al mese e potenzialmente proprio essere
esteso riportare il veicolo a terra a
riconsegnare il carico per tutte le post
light analysis il punto è che come
quando è nato il per
la diffusione del personal computer poi
è nato internet all'inizio ci si
chiedeva
quante applicazioni
che cosa ci si può fare con un compiuto
un personal computer e internet quello
che abbiamo era impossibile da prete
determinare prima era ancora ignoto
e qui c'è un parallelismo perché c'è un
piccolo veicolo il personal computer dei
vicoli di lancio che dalla
potenzialmente la possibilità a chiunque
di accedere un veicolo che terminerà la
ricerca e sviluppo
entro la fine del prossimo anno fine
voli su primi voli suborbitali orbitali
e poi vedrà la commercializzazione ma
c'è di più le tecnologie centrali che
stiamo sviluppando hanno la possibilità
di essere scalate in un veicolo più
grande che non trasporta solo cargo di
maggiore
cargo maggiore ma potenzialmente anche
esseri umani con la stessa semplicità di
operazioni o con una semplicità di
operazione estremamente simile
è tutto estremamente miniaturizzato
questo ad esempio è uno dei dieci motori
che si trovano che si trovano alla base
del veicolo ciascuno da 2.5 kg newton
questi dieci motori pensate
consentiranno al veicolo di raggiungere
le velocità orbitali
quindi vi lascio con l'augurio di un
grande con un augurio delle parole di un
grande
da qualche parte c'è qualcosa di
incredibile che attende di essere
scoperto qualunque sia questa cosa che
volete in giorno scoprire io vi dico
siate coraggiosi affrontate l'ignoto
trovate questa cosa
scopritela e se potete e se riuscite
portatela a beneficio del resto del
mondo
grazie
[Applauso]